right below me is the long trail of
blood keeps going and shitting I let it
or didn't is Moses or nobody keeping
right know the easiest thing to sell in
Chicago would you build this one play
like the devil is really working please
oh you love he is out here Joe here
without me put the knife down the Ruger
I just get on my knees I say guys just
give me one more
gun violence in Chicago an issue that
has caught the attention of news outlets
from around the world and perplex the
nation we arrived just after the city's
deadliest month in two decades August of
2016 alone
saw more than 400 people shot and at
least 78 homicides
we came here to take a look inside the
city's struggle with gun violence and
investigate what a city saturated with
firearms means for its communities the
problem has devastated countless
families as local elected officials held
their ideas to an exhausted City as big
a problem as gun violence is for Chicago
it is not beyond our ability to solve
much like other cities in America
violent crime is concentrated to
specific areas in 2016 the majority of
Chicago's nearly 800 homicides were
concentrated in the south and west sides
of the city what age you first start
rolling again most would so this is
awful - little smell - oh shoot oh yeah
and how old were you the first time that
you took them again
she's over there we sat down with
members of a renown street gang on
Chicago's West Side the black soul
how will we differ Spanish I thought we
went 50 and you were young we first
start seeing a good kill Emma would I
like play close go that's the me person
speaking about the head call it was nice
I'm a part of life you know
should we open a little far away
you speak and normal if you had to put a
number on it how many people do you how
many friends do you think you've lost
two guns oh come on now little girl for
many families in Chicago the pain of
losing someone to senseless violence is
too familiar that evening we attended a
vigil for a young man killed in the
South Lawndale neighborhood on Chicago's
West Side this whole day like the devil
is really working really really hard not
my brother died on September 2011 on a
sick and my nephew dad September 2016
on the sixth day soon we're gonna be on
the same day please all you junkie how'd
it go here without me put the gun down
we don't need to throw them put them
down
[Music]
gun related murders in Chicago have
reached a 20-year high too often single
mothers are left trying to make sense of
the loss of their child you want to see
all dis append up here
this was the Popeyes where he get killed
in Donna Hall is a male lady for the US
Postal Service
her son Marshall was gunned down at a
local Popeyes in the neighborhood where
she grew up
this is considered the Austin area and I
just feel so when I when I come when I
cross off into this way I just be like
oh no just no traffic please just let me
get to him going so I can get back cross
off this because of the gun violence
because of the values and just don't
know we tagged along with Donna as she
picked up her granddaughter Marshalls
daughter from school
[Music]
January 18 on a Friday he was inside a
pas pass some guy shot through the
window shot him on his shoulder and then
shot two of his fingers off then it shot
him in the back you know who killed your
son at yeah yeah mm-hmm but nobody wants
to talk and nobody wants to go to the
police shootings left unsolved by the
authorities sometimes lead grieving
friends and family with an urge to seek
justice on their own terms I was gonna
back up well you were thinking of buying
a gun yeah oh yeah why I was angry I was
mad your first instinct after your son
was killed by a gun was to go and get a
gun yourself simply to shoot his killer
or kill yourself mm-hmm to kill his to
get his killer
Stan kill myself yeah I didn't care how
his mama felt I didn't care I want her
to feel the same type of pain that them
what kept you
actually purchasing that gun I just got
on my knees si guys just give me one
more day the reality in the city's most
troubled neighborhoods is that today the
violence is rarely over gang business
and more often over trivial disputes
between small clicks you're right below
me is a long trail of blood the next
night we arrived in another vigil but
this one was different family and
friends were mourning the loss of their
loved one who had been shot when
suddenly they became the target
themselves the latest victims for
retaliation shooting Jay Butler had just
minutes earlier been grieving the loss
of his best friend when a car suddenly
drove by the vigil and opened fire this
is a disturbing but common retaliation
tactic yesterday they came back on the
counter
come out with the County inspector did
they came out tonight they strike a
moment man hey I shot his mother yes and
hit he's gone
talking to anybody man is too of this
cool oh I see this man that every day
but he did and it hurts even more when
he's you hear me when his people growing
up with he wouldn't expect like good
humor that that perspective molding your
own and mother you know I'm saying I
heard
estranged from his mother and living on
his own Jay told us that in less than 24
hours he'd lost the closest thing to a
family that he had ever had after
refusing to answer questions from the
police he walked away from our cameras
and didn't answer our calls the causes
of Chicago struggle with gun violence
are deep-seated often attributed to the
realities of life and pockets of the
city that have been neglected and
marginalized for decades
Chicago is unique to other big cities in
America because of the vast number of
guns flowing through its streets how
easy is it again hey it looks cute oh
yeah I could leave you right now a
little bit a mother woman
just like Wilson stole by the very tip
hey yeah what do you have here because
you're smoking okay right now but they
have can afford again shit now that it
is mostly low to keep me right no
there's not much a chamber gay club in
2016 over 8,000 guns were recovered by
law enforcement and the Chicago Police
Department saw 20 percent increase in
illegal gun seizures the easiest thing
to sell in Chicago was a gun so if you
got a gun and you broke you can sell
your gun like for whatever people will
buy a gun for whatever on average seven
times more guns are seized in Chicago
than in New York City and more than
twice as many as in Los Angeles
nobody's Chicago that I'd know a
manufacturer gun you know what I mean we
don't make guns we don't any claims and
only both no any trains the ship gun so
the question is how do so many guns get
here that's the quest that everybody
wanted no Andre Thomas is a former
leader of the Gangster Disciples a
street gang on the south side of Chicago
after serving a prison sentence for
murder he now works for cease fire a
grassroots violence interruption effort
you don't have super gangs anymore
that's over with
you have a lot of clicks a lot of kids
that involved me is click so the
question is where the hell are they
getting you go
to see exactly what Andre is talking
about simply log on to Twitter young men
flaunt their guns all over social media
to understand the daunting task of
tracking Chicago's gun problem we wrote
along with the Cook County sheriff's
police gun team we're among a handful of
law enforcement bodies working to stem
the flow of guns in Chicago one of the
tactics the unit uses is street stops
the team pulls over individuals for
minor infractions hoping to gain
information like worth tip we're on the
city's deep south side and the gun team
receives just that a hit from a young
man on whom they found a bag of
marijuana you know will one of them how
often do these guys say they don't
cooperate they usually work out or not
so well where's it going please going to
stay here the team locates the gun in a
trash can behind the home of an
oblivious resident
what is it
the ruger this Macon style is common on
the streets of Chicago while some days
are better than others for the team this
time it took four police officers
working eight hours to recover a single
gun it's estimated that roughly six
thousand illegal guns were pulled off
the streets
each year we followed the team back to
the sheriff's headquarters where the gun
was dropped off to evidence control for
tracing we got a glimpse of all the guns
they'd seized from just the past six
months just looking around the evidence
room here you get a pretty good picture
of the large variety of guns that
they're pulling off the streets of
Chicago there's everything from old
hunting rifles that look like something
your grandfather would have used to
brand new ar-15 22s Glock 9 like pretty
much anything you can imagine we later
learned that the Ruger 9-millimeter gun
that they collected from the street was
traced back to its initial sale at a gun
store outside the city limits Chicago
has some of the most stringent gun laws
in the country yet a stunning number of
guns are recovered here more than any
other big city in America the situation
begs the question where do all these
guns come from it's usually
intermediaries who are responsible for
putting guns in the hands of criminals
meaning straw purchasers brokers and gun
traffickers and over 60% of these guns
associated with gangs originate from out
of state the leading supplier being
nearby Indiana you don't think that
you'll ever be able to stop the flow of
guns in Chicago probably not do you
think that stricter laws would help if
the laws are always good as long as them
force
why does gun violence perpetuate itself
so much here in Chicago well I think it
begins with the fact that Chicago is one
of the most segregated cities in the
world and across the city I see a lot of
people probably living in below the
poverty line and so what you see is
people fighting for their survival I
don't think that people would choose to
live this way if they had an option that
they had another way of living if they
had somewhere you know honest honest way
to make a living I don't I don't think
that people would chew who were one
live like that they really really had on
a choice what do you think has to be
done to curb the violence Oh God
so most people eat that any means mister
everybody necessary for more fighters I
don't really know money almost
automobiles upon this muscle right here
okay
other issues in our documentary series
include the rise of high-powered assault
weapons the battle to carry guns on
campus and the controversy over smart
gun technology - check out our entire
documentary series subscribe to aj+ and
watch more docs
[Music]